Amidst fireworks, bright lights,
and a foreboding warning, one
moment in the new trailer for Season 3 of "The
Mandalorian" has fans buzzing with excitement.
There's a new trailer for the third season of
"The Mandalorian," and that means "Star Wars"
fans everywhere are coming together to find every
small detail it teases. This includes the return
of characters like Captain Carson Teva, Dr.
Pershing, Peli Motto, Greef Karga, and more.
We also saw an allusion to the past of "The
Mandalorian" in the form of a statue of IG-11
commemorating his sacrifice. There's also the
return of the iconic B1 droids, which are often
the butt of jokes in series such as "Star Wars:
The Clone Wars" and "Star Wars: The Bad Batch."
"Huh? What's happening?"
"I don't know. Did we win?"
However, there's one detail in particular
that fans on Reddit found particularly
interesting and believe might hint at what might
be happening in "The Mandalorian's" third season.
At about one minute into the trailer, we see a
bustling city with tall skyscrapers and flying
ships everywhere. Although the galaxy likely
holds more than one city with that description,
the most iconic one in "Star Wars"
is almost definitely Coruscant,
which is a planet entirely
covered by a giant city.
On Reddit, one user simply exclaimed,
"Coruscant!!!", with another adding, "Post
Episode 6 Coruscant!!" This is notable because,
at least in the "Star Wars" shows and films,
we have never seen the city planet chronologically
after "Star Wars: Return of the Jedi." This means
that we would get to see Coruscant as we've
never seen it before, potentially gaining news
on what has happened there since the dismantling
of the Empire and the death of Emperor Palpatine.
Another Redditor wrote,
This is referring to a scene in "The Force
Awakens" in which the First Order destroys
the similar-looking city planet, which
led many to believe Coruscant was no more.
As has been shown recently in the 2022
series "Andor," Coruscant is where most
of the franchise's politics take place, as it is
the home of whatever government tends to rule the
galaxy at the time, whether it be good or evil.
Since "The Mandalorian" takes place after the
Galactic Empire but before the rise of the First
Order, this may be one of the few times we get
to see the planet in relative peace, though
we know that this peace will be short-lived.
Of course, fans on Reddit are excited
by this possibility. A user wrote,
Responding to this comment, another Redditor said,
This is because the New Republic decided
to make their home planet Hosnian Prime,
which doesn't seem to appear in any of the
trailers for "The Mandalorian" Season 3 so far.
Although many people believe the planet is
Coruscant and are excited by the prospect,
others aren't as convinced.
One Reddit user believes the planet
might actually be Hosnian Prime,
which also features lots of skyscrapers and, being
the capital of the New Republic, might make more
sense to feature if they're indeed delving
into that government's politics. They write,
Another Redditor isn't convinced the planet
is either of those two, however, writing,
They might be right since the planet was
referenced in "Andor." With this new relevance
to Chandrila, it might be time to finally get a
closer look at the planet, especially since it
served as the first capital of the New Republic
before it was ultimately moved to Hosnian Prime.
"The Mandalorian" Season 3
premieres on Disney+ on March 1st.